hola entonces estás remontadas que hizo
el equipo 'merengue' como no hablar de
las remontadas tres remontadas
consecutivas ha realizado el real
madrid- como les decimos desde octavos
cada una más épica que la anterior en
octavos de final cayeron en la ida por 1
a 0 en casa del pdl en el bernabéu
perdían por 1 a 0 y terminaron ganando 3
a 1 en el partido y 3 a 2 en la
eliminatoria en cuartos ganaron 3 a 1 al
chelsea en londres en el bernabéu
perdían 3 a 0 luego marcaron dos goles y
ganaron la llave por 5 a 4 de ayer la
remontada de las que venimos de
hablarles en la historia queda en el
recuerdo la remontada contra el derby
county en la entonces copa de europa de
la temporada
1975-1976 el madrid cayó 4 a 1 en la ida
de segunda ronda y en la vuelta ganó 5 a
1 victoria 6 a 5 en el global en la copa
de la uefa también hay un importante
antecedente el madrid perdió en
semifinales 3 a 1 contra el inter en
italia y ganaron 5 a 1 en el bernabéu